thank you very much it is it is my great
honor and distinct pleasure to be here
today back in a room where I took
several different classes actually but I
I was asked to come back after last
spring I had made a presentation to the
Stanford venture capital Club I guess
and I did as part of that presentation
talking about venture capital I did my
top ten lies of entrepreneurs and VCS so
I gather the organizers asked me to come
back and do an encore performance
but it wasn't which I'm delighted to do
but it wasn't crystal clear from the
title on the program exactly what the
session was supposed to be about so if
there is any confusion you know why I'm
talking about lies the point of this
session is to talk about that process of
venture capital where the entrepreneur
and the VC get together to talk about
raising capital so there's a lot of
discussion in entrepreneurship about
building companies and building teams
and strategy and all that stuff not a
lot of discussion about that that fairly
unique odd little experience that
entrepreneurs have which is talking to
VCS and raising capital and then dealing
with the VCS so in order to try to make
some what light and interesting of what
is otherwise a fairly serious and
painful topic we we created a garage a
series of of lies that VCS tell
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs tell
lies as a way of elucidating the process
and trying to talk a little bit about
what works and what doesn't work when
you're raising capital with venture
capitalists to be to be more precise the
origin of this particular this
particular session was way back when we
were starting garage I was at a
conference one of those big VC
conferences where you get entrepreneurs
on stage and they get six minutes to
expose their lives to an audience filled
with feces who are passing judgment on
them so you pay thousands of dollars to
go to these things and I was at that
point I felt like an interloper I had
been an entrepreneur all of my
career I had been on the other side of
the table the guy who stood up there and
exposed his life and now I was in the
audience and I was sitting with the VCS
and I was standing in the back of the
room listening to the entrepreneurs
watching them feeling their pain and
there in the back of the room next we
were two VCS and one VC turns to the
other and he says how do you know when
an entrepreneur is lying and the other
VC kind of looks at him and goes I'm not
sure how and the first VC says his lips
are moving so the point is if you're a
VC and you're listening to pitch after
pitch after pitch after pitch you know
in spite of what everybody says about
the importance of entrepreneurial
passion and enthusiasm and optimism
the reality is investors really don't
want to invest in people who are out of
touch with reality and so what happens
however is all of us who are
entrepreneurs and our enthusiasm we tend
to stretch the truth and by doing so we
lose credibility with investors and so
from an investor point of view to twist
another adage there are lies there are
damn lies and there are business plans
and so the point of this presentation is
to talk a little bit about typical areas
where entrepreneurs tend to go beyond
the bounds of appropriate passion
enthusiasm and tend to misrepresent the
reality of their business so with that
let's go through the top 10 lies of
entrepreneurs when pitching to venture
capitalists lie number one is our
projections are conservative so
virtually now every entrepreneur has
been taught not to say this but the
reality is when you get down and dirty
into financial projections every
entrepreneur has to at some point they
come to that point in the sentence when
they say but but but there's so many
things we can do I mean there's so many
other markets there's so many other
products these projections are really
real
me and they you know they're trapped at
that point and they look at them you
know they stand up and they say
conservative realistic I really think we
can hit them but the reality is the
reality is everybody misses their
projections and so does on the one hand
and every VC knows you're going to miss
your projections and the point of
projections is not to be precise and
accurate the point of projections is to
tell the story of your business and what
it could be so on the VC side we never
really really expect you to hit the
projections we certainly hope you're
going to hit the projections and we
certainly want to understand the logic
behind the projections but the fact that
you're an entrepreneur means by
definition they can't be conservative
because entrepreneurs by definition
aren't conservative so don't say our
projections are conservative my number
two our market is 56 billion dollars and
again you know MBA after MBA
entrepreneur after entrepreneur pulls
out statistics from IDC and Frost and
Sullivan and all of you know Gartner
group with these reports that say hey
you know by the year 2010 conservatively
projecting this market is going to be 56
billion dollars but of course all that
shows the investor is that you haven't
done good market segmentation because
certainly no entrepreneur no startup
company is targeting a fifty six billion
dollar market you know best case you're
going to get some fraction of a fraction
of a percent and that's not really what
business is about and so what you want
to do as an entrepreneur building your
business plan is you want to carve up
that market and figure out what in fact
is the sub segment of that market that
you're targeting because from the point
of view of the investor saying your
market is 56 billion means that you
don't really understand the narrow
specifics of your market and the
opportunity that you're targeting line
number three our contract with Cisco
Microsoft Oracle whatever our contract
is going to be signed next week so one
of the dirty one of the dirty little
secrets about the venture capital
funding process is that when you walk in
and you pitch an investor
you're not going to get a check that day
it's going to be an extended process in
fact it's going to be months not just
weeks between the time that you meet
with the investor and the time that
they're actually going to close the deal
so anything you say to an investor about
something that's going to happen within
the next six months had better happen it
damn sure better happen but in all of
your enthusiasm because you know you've
got a contract in legal at Cisco you
know you want to share this wondrous
story of how you're about to close Cisco
right but inevitably inevitably it's
going to get quote hung up and legal or
somebody's going to go on vacation or
something like that and you have just
said to the VC last week our contracts
going to close you know next week two
weeks later they finally get around to
following up and they say oh yeah that
contract that closed last week how's it
going well you know and so all of a
sudden you've blown your credibility
again because in the space of one week
you've already failed to live up to your
projections if you can't if you can't
hit a one-week deadline how the hell you
going to hit a five-year deadline right
so if you've got a lot of great stuff
going on while you're talking with the
investors play it low-key only talk
about the stuff that you've actually
accomplished you know thrill the
investors with what you have in fact
accomplished a date and then in the
weeks that follow surprise them delight
them with the news that you've closed a
new contract you've got another customer
you've got a beta you've got you know
you've hired some you know wondrous
Talent don't promise things unless your
apps are absolutely sure that you're
going to deliver it line number four if
we only sell 40% of the company we'll
still have control now one of the big
concerns entrepreneurs have is the
structure of the cap table they're
anxious about you know kind of at what
point can those investors wake up on the
wrong side of bed and decide to throw
my ass out of here and you know that's
it's a reasonable concern but the
assumption that happens sort of outside
the VC room the VCS aren't in the room
and then the-- you know the
entrepreneurs are sitting there looking
at term sheets or thinking about
valuation issues and they're thinking to
themselves was long as we don't sell 51%
of the company you know we'll still
control this company two big problems
with that one it's wrong you know as
soon as you sell a single share of stock
to somebody else you have a fiduciary
responsibility to other people you know
so that's just sort of basic law but the
second issue the second issue is that
this raises a huge red flag for
investors if you're concerned about
control if you're concerned if you have
a point of view starting at the
beginning that you have an adversarial
relation to the Senate ownership it
doesn't set up a lovely relationship
with your investors so you want you
first of all if you are anxious about
control then you got to make sure you
work with investors that you like to
work with people who have a reputation
for integrity honesty being straight
with you who you know aren't going to
screw you but you got to pay attention
to the fact that it's not about the
percentage of the cap table it's about
your relationship with your investors
and your performance as an entrepreneur
line number five there's no competition
in our space we hear you know all sorts
of variations on this particular theme
one is you know there's there's no
direct come there's no direct competitor
throw there's the other famous one is no
one else can do what we can do so that's
a form of non competition I suppose the
question of course is do you understand
what competition means when you're
building a business there's no
competition in our space implies that
nobody's doing what your solution
promises to do because if nobody is
because if somebody is doing it then
there's an alternative to your solution
and if there's an alternative to your
solution then of course there's
competition it's that
usually and frequently for early-stage
companies that alternative is the status
quo it's either you know doing it
yourself or using an old technology to
do it but if somebody is if if you have
a value proposition whether it's to
speed up the infrastructure of an
enterprise network or if it's to offer
messaging over mobile phones to
consumers there are other there are
other solutions out there that may not
use your technology but they're an
alternative solution to achieve the same
value proposition so when people say
there's no competition we have one of
two reactions either maybe indeed nobody
in the face of the planet has ever done
this before in which case it's probably
not that interesting you know it's
probably a classic example of a
technology in search of a solution and
that's not to interest interesting or or
the entrepreneur gets up there and says
there's no competition when in fact you
know a couple of minutes on Google would
reveal the result sorts of competition
and then we realize the entrepreneurs
bozo and that's not conducive to raising
capital either so make sure no matter
what when you're talking about the
competitive environment at least you
acknowledge the status quo at least you
acknowledge you know the homebrew
solution or whatever the alternatives
are as a way of explaining how you're
going to compete in the marketplace and
what your competitive advantage is line
number six we've assembled a world-class
team now every once in a while this is
true but you know even for great
experienced serial entrepreneurs at the
early stage it's pretty much impossible
to have assembled a world-class team but
again everybody every on Twitter are
wants to be wants to be thrilled with
their partners and wants to show the
love that they've got for the team that
they've assembled and so you're sitting
in the conference room with you know
their roommate the engineer and their
wife's brother who is the sales guy and
you know you're standing up there and
saying you know we've got a world-class
team and they may be great people and
they may be perfect for the stage of the
company but they're probably not
world-class team and they're probably
people who are not going to be the
senior executives two or three or four
years from now assuming you're
successful and so I'm not suggesting
that you shouldn't be delighted with the
team you have but I'm suggesting it's
important to be realistic about the need
to evolve teams over time and that may
include you yourself independently as an
entrepreneur you may be absolutely the
right person to start this company up
but over time you may take a different
role an appropriate role in the in the
company as it grows excuse me why number
seven our sales cycle is three to six
months and that's conservative by the
way so you know this is yeah this is
probably the single biggest problem in
hitting financial projections hitting
goals and objectives for companies
everybody everybody gets this wrong and
I don't I don't know why that is you
know every you know you hear the you
hear the examples of course every once
in a while they're famous they're on the
covers of magazines because they
actually meet their plans right there
very few companies that actually hit
their sales plans and that's because
entrepreneurs you know people generally
miss estimate the sales cycle and one of
the reasons this happens and you know
having been this been through this
myself is you're sitting there you're
trying to plan out the operating plan
for the year and you're looking at your
pipeline and you know the customers
you've got going and you're looking your
products and all that and you're saying
to yourself okay you know let's look at
the last 10 deals we closed well you
know we look at the last 10 deals we
closed and they closed on average in
4550 days you know and so you know we've
got data we've got data that shows that
on average you know we close our deals
in 4550 days so let's be you know let's
hedge that a little we'll say three to
six months right but statistically and
in the real world what really has
happened is you've got ten deals you've
closed and you've got another forty
deals that you haven't closed right it's
the rest of the pipeline hopefully god
bless you you have 40 more deals on your
pipeline
but all of those 40 deals haven't been
averaged in two that 45 50 day
calculation so you're off by that factor
right you know however long it's going
to take to close all those guys actually
has to be averaged in and so again it
varies from business to business but
unfortunately the way the calendar works
the way humans work it's really really
hard for anybody to get a contract to
get a contract signed by an organization
in less than a six month period and
usually you know when just looking out
there at different businesses and enter
particularly if you're selling to
companies the time from the very first
meeting if you're talking if you're time
from a very first meeting through all
the evaluation through god bless it you
got a pilot you know god bless it you
got the CIOs got to sign off before
you're going to plug this thing into
anything you know and God bless legal
gets through it in less than 30 days
right it adds up nine 12 months minimum
to get these sorts of things done but
it's it's really hard when you're
putting together the operating plan of
the business plan forecast to admit that
you know it's going to take twelve
months on average to close each of these
deals so be very cautious about this and
be able to explain how it is that your
sales cycle is going to evolve in your
particular business ideally somebody on
your team has had a lot of experience
selling into your market and has a lot
of real-world experience and what all of
the elements of sales are but frequently
and this is one of the I think one of
the biggest issues facing a lot of
companies you know even facing the MBA
curriculum I think is that the
discipline of sales and sales processes
are not well taught well understood and
well managed in most startup companies
line number eight we have the first
mover advantage so this was actually
this was particularly exciting during
the bubble its I noticed you know it
kind of disappeared when the bubble
burst does this phrase but I noticed
it's coming back it's coming back
particularly in web get all these web
2.0
things because with web 2.0 you know
it's really easy to get something up and
running and you know so the game is who
gets the critical mass and the buzz and
you know the mentos video first right
and so it feels as though and I've even
you know read books by credible authors
about you know the importance of first
mover advantage and you know in some
cases it's taught in the curriculum
about you know the importance of being
first and that is the basis of market
share and market share is the basis of
the experience curve and the experience
curve is the basis of competitive
advantage and so first mover advantage
is you know historically it's an
important thing but the reality in
startup companies technology based
startup companies is there's a whole
bunch of stuff that can go wrong if
you're the first mover first of all
generally the first guys to have the
clever idea that you know once the
technology is good enough to enable you
to do something interesting like you
know integrated messaging systems using
your cell phone or something the problem
though is you've got the first
generation of technology protocols that
are going to be you know they're they're
not quite stitched together all that
well and they're still pretty expensive
and you got a lot of heterogeneity in
the system not a lot of standardization
and so frequently the first movers are
the guys that spend the most money
trying to get to market and at the end
of the day they wind up having a you
know mediocre solution and so they spend
a lot of money take a number of years
for you know enabling the market to
figure out how do we really want to do
this thing that these guys have invented
and then a whole bunch of other guys
come along swoop in take over the market
and so you see that time and time again
in the VC marketplace so when an
entrepreneur gets up and says you know
we're going to be the first movers
that's a red flag to us because we're
we're thinking to ourselves well first
of all are they really the first movers
in probably they aren't because probably
we've already seen four five six other
teams that may or may not be in stealth
who are doing exactly
same thing but secondly the question is
can they really get to market and stay
ahead of the curve or are you going to
wind up building a building a solution
on a platform of code that's going to be
obsolete in 18 months and the guys that
come along in 18 months using the
next-generation protocols the
next-generation standards they're going
to be able to get to market with a
solution that's even better than yours
in five weeks from the time of
introduction and you're going to be
scrambling because you're gonna have to
rewrite your entire code base from
scratch so it isn't necessarily the most
compelling business idea to be the first
guy to create a solution once a solution
becomes technically possible so that's
that's I got to tell you having been on
the entrepreneur side of this that's
that's a tough one because once you have
the idea you know you're standing there
in the shower thinking to yourself this
is a great idea right and nobody else
has done this yet wouldn't it be cool to
be the first guys to go do this and that
that probably can make sense
you just got to think through do you
have the resources and the staying power
to be the first guy out there and then
to also be the fast follower to be too
quickly cannibalize what you've learned
and get a new solution out there before
everybody else leapfrogs ahead of you
line number nine all we have to do is
get 2% of the market right so this is
the coral area of our market is 56
billion right so you get you you know
you segment your market carefully you
identify all the possibilities you know
after all there are now two billion cell
phones on the planet
right you know selling it close to a
billion a year so boy you know two
billion cell phones and all of them can
receive a text message right so let's
see I you know it's certainly possible
for me to get to a couple hundred
million cell phones that'd be pretty
easy to do wouldn't it I mean it's not
that many so it's really easy to talk
yourself into this sort of rule of large
numbers that says there's so much stuff
out there and there's so many people
doing things in this space
you know myspace is the other favorite
you know if I could just get a few
people to start a viral kind of adoption
of this widget on MySpace you know it's
a piece of cake for me to have 10
million people in you know implant my
widget on their MySpace page I mean of
course that's easy to do right so the
point is you get you get wrapped up in
how many people and how many how many
dollars and how many potential customers
there are for a given solution and there
you are looking at your Excel
spreadsheet and you're thinking yourself
I can't go to these VCS and tell them
we're going to be two billion dollars in
you know year three right because it's
you know it's unrealistic to be two
billion dollars in year three but at two
billion dollars that's only 10 percent
of the market right so you know so we'll
be conservative and we'll cut it back
well the problem there is not that
you've been optimistic about your market
share the problem is that you've missed
defined the market that you're going
after you know there's a very narrow for
most applications there is in fact a
very narrow customer base that you
really can go after who are likely to
adopt it within any sort of realistic
time frame so it's about narrowing your
target market of which you will then
have a significant percentage rather
than taking a big market and saying you
know we're going to start year one we
think we should be able to get 1/10 of
1% of the market and that's you know a
five million dollar company right so we
see this all the time you don't want to
take an arbitrarily large market and
then do a bottoms-up assumption on how
you're going to generate revenue what
you want to do is you want to isolate
the target prospects for your business
think about you know specifically who
are the customers who might buy your
product in the first 24 months and if
you're selling into business you should
be able to name them and figure out or
if you're selling into a consumer market
you should be able to identify the
channel by channels who you're going to
get to you know can you realistically
get into Best Buy in the first 12 months
of being a business or whatever I don't
know pick your market take it apart
deconstruct it and then figure out
bottoms up sales call by sales call
marketing campaign by marketing campaign
realistically how are you going to build
up these numbers against what market are
you targeting so if you say all you need
is 2% of the market as an investor we
say well you know either you don't
understand your market or we want to go
after the company that's going after the
other 98% and then line number 10 my
number 10 is I'll be happy to hand over
the reins to a new CEO this goes back
you know to your world-class team and it
goes back to you as an individual
entrepreneur as well that you know again
most entrepreneurs now have been coached
well enough to know that at some point
in time maybe they're not the right CEO
for this company the issue that
investors have is when the entrepreneur
says this are they in fact sincere or is
in fact what the entrepreneur saying in
subtext I will hand over the reins to a
new CEO if that new CEO is the right CEO
for my company right and that's just a
big red flag you know if you think it's
your company then we're likely to have a
problem that is a concern for investors
because it is not your company it is our
company it includes the rest of the
management team it includes the rest of
the investors it includes all the
employees it has to be a team effort if
you have an ego centric perspective that
this is your baby and your baby alone
and it's your job as steward of this
baby to make sure that you were the one
who decides who the right CEO is for the
company you're likely to butt heads not
just with your investors but with the
other people on your management team so
this is a way that investors can set out
what is the real ego involvement of the
entrepreneur in this in in this
particular company so those are the top
10 lives of entrepreneurs
I guess question is whether it's worth
taking some questions now or should I
dive into the to the other side of the
coin and take questions at the end so
anybody sitting here with an absolutely
earning pressing got to have an answer
to now kind of question or shall I go on
to the top 10 lies of VCs okay in that
case I will go on to the top 10 lies of
venture capitalists but first if I may
by the way while I'm am well I'm
catching my breath my dear friend here
Larry kubal you were also Stanford right
okay was suggesting to me that I have
not completed the four square matrix
here so we have entrepreneurs lying to
VCS and we have VCS lying to
entrepreneurs but as Larry points out
being a VC at a firm called Labrador
there's another dimension to this which
is VCS line to these seeds which is you
know extremely common you know you know
if I yeah someday somebody's going to
write the expose you know they're going
to get into somebody's email box and all
the you know all the pitches VC sent to
VCS about their you know oh wow I found
a great investment and you know we we
just put the seed money into this
company and it's going to be a rocket
and I'm gonna because you're my dearest
friend on earth I want to let you in on
this deal great so so Larry what you
think of that presentation so in any
case top 10 lies of venture capitalists
and again so here we are in this in this
surreal world you know you as an
entrepreneur trying to build a company
and you know you're really focused on
the important stuff right you know
getting products that work and
understanding the market and we're
lining up customers and building a team
and then you've got these other people
you got to deal with these guys called
venture capitalists and they're kind of
a different breed they're not like your
customers I mean your customers you know
how to talk to customers but these VCS
they don't react the same way as
customers and it's hard to understand
what's really going on in there
and so the point of this presentation is
to provide a guide to the language and
culture of venture capital it's sort of
a sort of a different world you're going
into and it's valuable to understand
what it is VCS are saying when they say
things like I like the way you think so
what do you really mean Larry when you
say I like the way you think huh okay
okay hey I'm not the SEC sure I
understand what you're saying but you
know unless I'm nice to you I won't hear
anything more right right right
so okay so with that let me share with
you our particular perspective on the
top 10 lies of VCS and by the way I
should assure you you know this was it
was really hard work distilling down
from the hundreds and hundreds of
possible lies but what happened in fact
was so you know I had developed this top
10 lies of entrepreneurs thing based
upon that conference I went to and we
gave it you know in a few cases and it
actually wound up getting published in
the Harvard Business Review and then
someone said well wait a second
you know how come you're not you know
giving equal time to the VCS and so guy
came up with a with the you know this
this idea we got to have top 10 lives of
VCS and we sat down and you know we went
through all these things that we said to
entrepreneurs and that we've heard other
people say to entrepreneurs over the
years as entrepreneurs and sitting on
that side of the table and so with that
try to do our best to distill it down to
the top 10 so line number one we like to
move quickly you know and you know so
again you know you go in you pitch to
the VCS and they'll tell you how their
streamlines I make quick decisions and
you know the partners let's see it's
Friday the partners meet Monday boy you
know you should have a check by Tuesday
as the impression you know they almost
give and the reality is you know one
you know these these are people too and
they they over promise and under deliver
as a rule and but the the dirty little
secret underlying this particular point
is the the process really does take a
long time it does take months generally
from sort of the initial contact to
closing the deal and part of that is
because it's extremely valuable to the
investors to watch how you and your team
perform over the period of negotiation
with the VCS so it's you know we have
this inside garage I'll be disclosing
here and I probably shouldn't be but I
will and anything so we we refer to
deals as either microwave or slow bake
and sometimes you get a deal and you say
okay maybe this is a microwave kind of
deal now 60 seconds boom we want to cook
it and we want to make it happen and
generally from a VC point of view it's a
microwave deal if you're afraid that
that you know if you don't move quickly
something bad will happen and usually
there's something bad that will happen
if somebody else will take the deal
right you know or this you know
sometimes we're more altruistic than
that and we say if we don't move quickly
then we won't get the market opportunity
we won't be able to take advantage of
the market opportunity quickly enough
but that's extremely rare almost every
deal in the venture capital community
can be a slow bake and the reason slow
bake is good for the investor is again
they get to see how things evolve over
the weeks and months that pass so when
you go in you pitch a VC and they say we
like to move quickly be very very
realistic about this and understand that
you know it's going to be it's going to
be multi multi weeks if not multiple
months in the process and that there
everything you do in that process is
being evaluated it's not just about
what's written on paper or what was on
your slide presentation
it's about your performance about it's
about when and how you return calls it's
about the quality of your emails it's
about you know whether you actually
deliver on what you
said you would do the prior week all of
these signals as to the quality of you
and your team as an entrepreneurial team
really really matter and that's part of
the data that's being gathered yeah they
talk about the formal due diligence
process and you know they have lawyers
that look at contracts and they look at
your patent your patent applications but
that stuff is really less important than
how you're behaving over that period of
weeks BC line number two we're
value-added investors you know we can
really help you build your company what
they're really saying is because we're
such great guys and such a great team we
have such a great network you of course
should take a lower price in the
valuation of your company you don't want
dumb money right
you don't want dumb money you want to
value at an investor you know surely
anybody who bids higher for your equity
then we bid you know must be dumb money
right kind of by definition
so we're value-added investors is all
about saying you know we are going to
help you with more than just money now I
don't mean to suggest I don't mean to
suggest that VCS aren't value at
investors you know Labrador ventures for
example is an extraordinarily capable
venture fund in terms of helping
companies build their companies right
helping operators build their companies
but when you're in a meeting before
they've invested and they say this part
of what they're setting you up for is
when and if we give you a term sheet and
you notice that our pre-money valuation
is lower than some other firms pre-money
valuation the reason for that is that
we're going to make you richer because
we're value-added investors so that's
the subtext of that particular statement
corollary to that is we have a great
network part of being a value-added
investor and when you probe down into
that what you find out is that network
network network includes things like my
son plays baseball with Scott McNealy
son lie number four I really like your
company I just couldn't convince my
partners
basically what they're saying is I don't
want to have to admit to you that I just
wasted a bunch of your time going
through this process it is in all
fairness to venture capitalists it is
you know it's a very challenging process
that you see you know a great team with
a great idea with a lot of energy and a
lot of potential but the challenge for
entrepreneurs is not is not proving it's
not proving that you have a good idea
that could generate a lot of money the
reality is your that's that's not the
proof point that's not where you're
trying to convince the investors what
you're trying to convince the investors
is that you're the best next investment
for their fund that's a very different
sales proposition than proving that
you're a good idea and the problem for
you
unlike selling to a customer if you're
selling to a customer you know exactly
what the alternatives are right you know
don't buy the Cisco router by our right
router because our writers spec spec
spec spec spec benefit benefit benefit
benefit you know you can sell against
the known competition when you're
selling to customers when you're selling
to VCS you don't know what the
competition is right you don't know what
are the term sheets they have out or who
else they're talking to and so there you
are thinking that you've got a great
brilliant idea and you've actually got a
partner who probably is genuinely
enthusiastic about your company but it
may be that you're number four on their
list you know being number four on the
list is not at all bad it's just not
good enough to get a term sheet and so
on some Monday morning meeting with
partners they sit down and they say yeah
you know that team that came in really
really interesting let's keep looking at
them but no we're not going to we're not
going to deliver a term sheet and this
guy comes back in says you know how I
said I thought I could have a term sheet
by September let's see it's January
oh yeah my I really want but my
partner's it was my partner's who
wouldn't let me do it so that's what the
dynamic that's really going on behind
the scenes line number five
we like to syndicate huh what that means
is if Sequoia gets excited about this
you know we'll be happy to come in so
again this is a little unfair to these
C's because VC is in fact do like to a
need to syndicate but there's a
difference between a VC that is happy to
take the lead and drive the process
versus a VC that says to you if you find
a lead let us know right so if if if the
VC says to you if you find a lead
investor let us know what that VC is
telling you and very clear distinct
languages no we're not investing right
so the on the other hand if a VC says
you know we like to syndicate and you
say great who are your best friends and
they say I'm going to call up you know
Larry and Howe and Tim you know this
afternoon and we'll get together and
we're going to put this together that's
very different if they're actually going
to do the work to build the syndicate
that's a great thing it's a great thing
if you get a lead investor who's going
to sell your deal to other VCS if you've
got an investor who says they're
enthusiastic but he's not willing to
sell your deal to other VCS then they're
not a qualified investor for your
company well I number six we need to see
a little more traction this is a famous
one again what the investor is really
saying is we're not going to invest but
you know as Larry pointed out I don't
want to close I don't want to close off
my options because I really like the way
you think I don't want to close off my
options this may be an interesting deal
let's stay in touch
which is a way of saying report back to
us on a weekly basis what sort of
progress you're getting so the the
challenge for the VCS again as I as I
learned to appreciate after cutting over
to the other side the dark side as they
say is that every good deal
every good deal in the history of edge
venture capital was once a bad deal
right Yahoo was a really stupid idea for
the first 24 investors
that looked at it you know nobody would
invent nobody would invest at YouTube
when the guys first launched YouTube
right nobody would invest in you know
pick a company right every successful
company was a bad idea to a large number
investors and then something clicked
usually rarely was it that you know they
you know magically the right investor
came along and the clouds parted you
know and the heavenly chorus explained
the brilliance of the business idea to
that particular investor that's rarely
kind of the way the dynamic really works
usually what happens is the team gets
rejected and they tweak the model and
they work a little harder and they seek
out advice and then they get rejected
again and then they tweak the model and
they seek out advice in the build team
and then they get rejected again and
then finally after twelve or fourteen
tweaks they click on something you know
something happens and they get a beta
test at some company or some advisor
comes in and opens up the door to some
big company something happens that
changes the optics of the deal and then
all of a sudden the investors have a
different perspective on this deal so
the challenge for entrepreneurs a
challenge for entrepreneurs is having
the staying power to do 12 to 14
iterations before you get it right and
then what every investor knows is after
the money goes in you're going to have
to go through at least two or three
iterations one more you know again
before you get it right but as an
investor you want to see the first
twelve or fourteen done in somebody
else's nickel you don't want the first
twelve to fourteen done on your nickel
so that's why investors say we need we
need to see a little more traction and
why it's perfectly legitimate for you to
both hear it as a no but if in fact you
can tweak it and change your model go
back and find out if they're going to
say something more substantive line
number seven we invest in teams what
they're really saying is you know
assuming the technology works and
assuming this is a huge market we invest
in teams right and what the investors
want you to know is you know you hear
this all the time on these panels
is that the success of a company is a
function of the team does the team have
the flexibility and the knowledge and
the domain experience and the talent and
the you know the right ego and the right
confidence to evolve a business into a
successful business
teams are in fact critical but part of
what the investors are saying to you
when they say we reinvest in teams is
they're trying to give you comfort that
we think you're the right team and again
they may in fact think you're the right
team for exactly this moment in the
company except for the fact that as soon
as the money goes in we got to go hire a
new CEO because you know your roommate
just doesn't quite cut it he may be a
good coder but he's not a CEO and then
we got to go higher you know a guy who's
really a VP of engineering who really
has experience developing products you
know on time on budget but for right now
today this week the team you know is the
right team so from an investor point of
view we're not expecting the team to be
the complete team when we write the
check but we are expecting that the team
works effectively together that you're
perfectly capable of living on rice
cakes and mountain dew for an indefinite
period of time and most importantly that
you're capable of attracting
high-quality successors to each of you
in your positions it's that issue of is
there a dynamic here the you know this
combination of excitement and
opportunity and capability and
competence that make will make other
people want to jump on this team that
will make very talented people give up
their options in another company and
give up a higher salary to come take
advantage of this opportunity that's
what we're looking at when we talk about
investing in teams line number eight and
the board meeting so from now on I guess
the next three lies are sort of post
investment lies okay so imagine you
actually got through the hurdle and now
now we're at the board meeting at the
board meeting one of the one of your
investors says you know when we were
doing this at Cisco I watch out but that
really means is all I've got is a hammer
and you're looking like a nail to me you
know the adage about if all you've got
is a Hammer Every Problem looks like a
nail and there is a challenge there is a
challenge in the VC community that a lot
of us come from very specific
backgrounds you know I come from a
software background and so a lot of my
experience and a lot of my scars have to
do with getting software out into a
market through channels to customers big
sales small sales channel sales all that
stuff and you know on time on digit
budget hitting plan so I've got all of
this historical experience in my brain
that that filters every problem I see
when I'm sitting on a board and so the
challenge you've got as an entrepreneur
is you've got this entrepreneur who made
several of this venture capitalists who
made millions of dollars because he was
employee number 785 at Cisco so plate
number 785 and Cisco made millions of
dollars that's pretty cool right and
this guy thinks he was there you know
and he'll what he'll say is you know I
was there at the beginning right I
wasn't play number 785 right and so they
tend to assume that gives them wisdom
about start-up experience right so I
really don't mean to pick on X Cisco
people I apologize if there's anybody
there who made millions of dollars in
Cisco but in any case there is this
tendency for VCS to have a certain
perspective it's one of the most
important reasons to have more than one
investor in your company and what
sometimes happens that is a challenge
for entrepreneurs you know sometimes
they get a sole investor whether it's a
VC or an angel a sole investor as the
investor in their company and you know
if you can do something to counter that
I strongly urge it because there is a
tendency if you have a sole investor for
that person to say this is my money and
I know how to do things the right way
and let me tell you how to do them so
you got to watch out for this particular
VC line number nine is you're at the
board meeting things aren't quite quite
going right
but the you haven't spent a lot of time
talking with your investors on this and
at the board meeting the investor says
you should lean on us for help
and the challenge you've got there is
what the NVC is really saying is I don't
know what's going wrong here I don't
understand what's going wrong
otherwise I would have told you what you
should have done right but if they say
you should lean on your board it means I
don't have the answer but we need to
spend more time trying to figure out
what's going wrong on how to get to the
right answer
line number 10 is m and line number 10
is good work and what that means is I'm
probably not going to fire you this week
so again
yeah the challenge fraud Twitter's and
investors is if you make the quarter
that's great but you know if you miss
the next quarter I don't care if you
made the last quarter what I care about
is that you missed the next quarter and
that's the the challenge that investors
have so understand again the culture of
the VC who is reporting back to his
partners each quarter on the performance
of the companies that he's watching over
and you know you go back into your
partners meetings and you talk about
well there's this challenge and there's
that challenge and no matter what the
facts and circumstances one of your
partners is going to say well is that
guy the right CEO you know should we be
thinking about a change right and so
that's the the the problem for the VCS
is that VCS are all taught that
fundamentally their sole responsibility
for managing an investment is the
decision of the CEO and when to fire the
CEO so it's all about you know should we
make a change in the CEO position and
it's a perfect it's a perfectly
legitimate model for board governance
and board dynamics but the challenge for
an entrepreneur is once you take
investors on once you take on a board
it's that board's responsibility to
evaluate you continuously and so if you
you know if you do perform well that's
great
keep up the good work
if things are going wrong you have to be
aware of the fact that the board is
going to be thinking at some point maybe
it's time for a change and so what a lot
of entrepreneurs do is they then hunker
down and that's not necessarily the best
solution the entrepreneurs that survive
the process of the entrepreneurs that
open up and they reach out and if
something is going wrong
instead of ducking it and saying let's
have fewer board meetings this year you
know why don't we just have a board
meeting every six months that's a
natural entrepreneur instinct right
instead of doing that you go out to
lunch with each one of your investors
and you lay out what's happening and you
talk about what you've done and what
you've accomplished and you talk about
what you identify as the challenges and
you say what you wanted what you want to
make sure all of your investors know and
all of your board members know is that
you do understand what the challenges
are and you do have a plan on how to
address them and you've got the team
lined up and you are taking action as
soon as a board sees or investor see
that you're trying to duck
responsibility you're trying to duck a
communications role then they get scared
or and scared or and you create this
this vicious cycle of antagonism between
the entrepreneur and the board as
opposed to collaboration between the
entrepreneur and the board so I use this
as tongue-in-cheek around a very serious
issue about communication with boards
and again every every entrepreneur is
taught when they start a board that the
most important thing to do with the
board is not surprise the board right
you've never surprised the board if
someone walks into a board meeting and
hears bad news for the first time that's
a bad thing because what they want they
want to know the bad news before the
board and they want to know that there's
going to be discussion of how to address
the bad news not a communication that
there is bad news so as an entrepreneur
as a manager your job is to make sure
that all the communication gets to the
board early as soon as possible you
never want to hit a board member to hear
bad news from someone else and that as
quickly as you can you have reached out
to try to find alternate solutions
suggestions and that you as the senior
manager in the company have these
proposals or plans in place as to how
address it even if the plan is simply a
plan to figure out how to address the
problem
it's better than avoiding the problem
altogether or just sitting there saying
you know we missed the quarter I guess
we'll just have to try harder next
quarter right you better explain why you
missed the quarter you better explain
how you're going to try harder what
you're going to change about your
business otherwise you're going to lose
the confidence of your investors so with
all in all seriousness and all humor
those are the top 10 lies of venture
capitalists again I don't know I guess I
don't know if they I did send some
slides I don't know if they're available
on some website or not but if you want
the slides just send me an email at
Reichert across a calm you can find them
there if you have comments questions
follow-up thoughts whatever you can also
get me at my email address we also on
our website have some other stuff for
entrepreneurs we have a guide on how to
write a compelling executive summary we
have a guide on perfecting your pitch we
have a few other things some of guy
Kawasaki's speeches and then guy my
partner has also written a book called
the art of the start which is a
compilation of everything we've learned
in the eight years of of garage and he
maintains a blog which he has recently
renamed how to change the world you'll
be stunned too you'll be stunned to know
well you know you heard it here first it
that will be the title of his next book
probably so he figures if he just writes
a blog a day for you know some period of
time eventually he'll have enough words
for a book and so that makes it a lot
easier than sitting down and actually
writing a book but so I with that having
been said any any questions any comments
yes sir
I understand how you have a half a lie
okay what question was about to in the
business plan when you're doing the
projections I've done a number of
pitches and I've been given advice
before to kind of pump up the
projections by about twenty percent
because the piece is going to cut them
back anyways and I actually tried wants
to do I call it a realistic plan with
the longer sales cycles and so forth and
the plant those plans just kind of hit
the ground with bud having good there
seems to be this dynamic I just wouldn't
give any advice about how to break
through that word so he's expecting a
pump does you know I haven't cut it down
right well so again I mean every every
situation varies but and there's a you
know even within my partnership we have
controversies around this topic but my
my experience is that that Excel the
spreadsheet should putting in you know
what you think is realistic even with
six month nine-month 12-month seal
cycles you should discover you know
miraculously that's still a huge
business right if it isn't a huge
business even with quote unquote
realistic assumptions then you got to
drill in understand you maybe in fact it
is going to take more work and maybe in
fact you got to figure out you know is
your pricing wrong is your market
penetration value I mean is it going to
take more capital to get to a bigger
business than I would like so it's not
usually the problem that even when you
tailor back the numbers that the numbers
look totally uninteresting right now the
to get to the rules of thumb right
everybody wants to know you know is it
true that I have to have a hundred
million dollars on my revenue line
somewhere in my financial projections
and I would say that the answer to that
is unfortunately yes that is generally
true is it likely that you will in fact
hit the hundred million dollars you know
within five so generally that's the
fifth year projection and the reason
that entrepreneurs do five years of
projections is that it's just not
realistic to get to a hundred million in
anything less than Phi
of yours so the other reason by the way
to do five years of projections is and
this is where guy and I differ guys
attitude is we know they're lying so why
do we even bother asking for five years
you know and my point is well of course
they're not right but you've got to give
the company you got to give the
entrepreneur enough space to flesh out
the company to actually explain how the
company is going to evolve because the
first 24 months are one product one
market that's just the reality of a
business you can't can't get to more
than one product one market in the first
24 months so you'll want to understand
what the team is thinking in terms of
the next market in the next product and
that means you got to go three four or
five years but the other good reason to
go to five years is it gives you the
chance to get to a hundred million and I
hate saying it cavalierly that you know
you've got to figure out a way to get to
one hundred million not another case in
this business but there are some
circumstances though we're getting to 40
50 60 million is perfectly fine if you
can get there and you're still growing
fast and you're obscenely profitable at
truly profitable as opposed to Excel
profitable right then you can get a half
billion dollar valuation on a company
like that so so from a VCS point of view
hey you know if I can get comfort that
there's at least a hundred to two
hundred million exit here and the
possibility of upside to that and I've
got a reasonably sized fund then I can
be excited around a company like that so
that's what's going on the VCS head is
what can my exit look like and so the
gamesmanship though is as soon as as
soon as I see a yellow flag around your
projections then I start carving back
you know as soon as I think you're being
somewhat unrealistic then I assume
you're unrealistic on what unrealistic
across a whole bunch of stuff and I just
keep carving back so if I believe you're
being realistic and if I believe that
there might possibly be some upside I'm
not going to carve back so that's you
know that's the guy
that is the game you're playing if I
have any suggestion if there's any
suggestion you pumped up the numbers you
know then that's the last meeting and I
just you know there's there's so much
room in the marketplace for successful
companies that to have to pump numbers
is like you know forget it why you know
why would I bother right so uh yeah that
was hopefully that helped I don't know
yes it was more also about like how much
the investors want versus how much times
burns your seeking at what target
percentage ownership you know those kind
of issues and get involved
kind of how the pieces think about that
but you know how they're usually R
mismatched between entrepreneurs some
pcs on that issues yeah yeah so one of
the one of the important dynamics in the
venture capital world is that funds have
gotten bigger and bigger and meaning if
there's more and more money to put to
work and there aren't necessarily more
good deals or good opportunities but as
a result you are seeing VCS sort of
pushing out at the edges and you know
going International and going into clean
tech and all that sort of stuff because
they're trying to find places to put
money to work but one of the challenges
you know for you for any given
entrepreneur is I'm a fund I'm a you
know four hundred million dollar fund I
see your particular business plan I want
in any given situation I would like the
opportunity to make my fund on my
investment in your company right meaning
I want four hundred million dollars back
out of out of investing in you and so
then you get the math working which is
what's the possible exit well you know
they're very few billion dollar exits in
this world right and so I'm going to
hope god bless everything goes right
you're a 500 million dollar exit I can't
make the math work right I got o ninety
percent of you what eighty percent of
you to get a five hundred dollar exit
you know that dog don't hunt so that's
the pressure that's the pressure I've
got as an investor to want a larger
percentage of your company because I'm
looking at possible exits and
much it can contribute to my fund and so
I want a larger percentage of your
company the counter pressure the counter
pressure is I want the team to be
motivated to build a great company so
I'm always going to work the angles to
make sure that the right three four five
guys in the team see a window for
becoming obscenely rich so I'm going to
keep carving out enough options but of
course the guys the founders if they're
not adding value anymore and they're
sitting off to the corner somewhere I
know they got their founder stock and
that's that I'm not that worried about
them if they're not contributing anymore
and the earlier investors you know the
early investors I'm not that worried
about them either right so but I am
worried about the key management and I'm
also worried the other piece I'm worried
about is my syndicate partners right so
I want to maximize my ownership interest
but I also want to attract a syndicate
partner alongside me because I don't
want to have to carry this company
myself so I got to carve enough out for
my syndicate partner so you see
companies getting recarved with every
round of investment the first round is
generally pretty easy right because
you're only you're asking for a modest
amount of money and there's plenty of
room and the cap table for the investors
to own 40% of the company and everybody
else in you know the founders own 60% of
the company and you got four million
dollars and you know come by everybody's
happy right but things go wrong there's
a down round you bring in some more
investors that's when that's when things
get really dicey and you see these
horrible cap tables where you know the
founders have been almost washed out and
these they know the seed investors the
angels are getting screwed and you know
so but there is no there's no I wouldn't
say there's any hard and fast rule
because there's so many different
scenarios there are some companies very
few that all they need is one round of
investment there are other companies you
know that are perfectly successful
companies but they're in their Series F
you know so you can have a successful
company that takes a lot of capital but
it's going to squeeze down the
percentages over time so did that
adequately duck your question
because a minimum percentage that they
would take or their minimum investment
amount where you get to the point again
this is not of interest to us yeah any
venture capital fund will tell you that
the minimum they'll take is 20% so you
know the argument is if you don't have
at least 20% then it's not worth the
bandwidth it's not worth the attention
it's not going to make a dent etcetera
etc what I'm seeing and Larry and
anybody else who's a VC tell me if you
see something different more and more
now I'm seeing the VC saying the minimum
is 25% got one VC that said our minimum
is 30% for a series a deal I mean are
you seeing minimums go up angel type
deals getting done I mean the angels are
sort of coming back and some very small
funds that are willing to do the angel
sort of seed startup money so but for
series a I've totally agree the minimum
they're going up especially for the
larger funds for the institutions right
that's a really important point there is
a whole community of investors out there
that is somewhat different than what I
was speaking of which are which are you
know angels and angel funds you know
sophisticated executives who are now
turning into angel investors in some
cases some cases they're a little less
sophisticated but they're really rich
you got to be careful in some cases it's
a small fund that it's basically their
money or their money and some other
friends and angel money and those in
those investors have some different
behaviors and I you know they they can
be a great way to get started you know
particularly if they have a particular
expertise that they can use to help your
company yeah
looking to take and if you know it's not
to capital-intensive and choose an
appropriately-sized
form at under the font size because the
dynamics of alia party I don't know
anything what do you say but yeah I mean
it is it's um you know we as a small
fund strongly endorse that point of view
you know and we see teams all the time
that just came back from you know XYZ
big billion dollar fund on Sand Hill
Road
who you know they can't believe when
they walked out of the meeting the VC
said you're not asking for enough money
and that you know that seem
counterintuitive to the entrepreneurs
you know and I thought I thought we were
supposed to be lean and mean and
efficient and all that stuff but there
is this countervailing pressure so yeah
thank you for that point yes
leasing entrepreneurs come to you saying
things and kind of bet on the
projections question saying stuff like
well you know revenue generation isn't
really a core competency for a consumer
internet company that's looking to show
hockey stick type growth so really the
exit is based on traffic and how
important are these types of revenue
projections in that scenario yeah well
I'll tell you we you know we have a we
have a sign on our whiteboard that some
and some entrepreneurs notice some don't
it's you know the universal traffic
signal with the red bar through it says
web 2.0 right
we are ye so this is us you know we're
we're very very skeptical of web 2.0
deals and you know I hate to lump it all
in one for and one in one bucket but the
idea you know boy I've been there before
that's based on eyeballs and advertising
you know they're certainly you can build
a successful company that way because we
have the proof points that you can build
a successful company that way but not
all 632 companies that look exactly the
same
are going to be
be as successful right and so from our
point of view our ability to pick the
one of the 632 that happens to get that
you know mentos video or whatever it is
and whatever you know social networking
video hosting whatever I just we yeah we
get these teams come in we get really
excited it's fun it's great it's cool
but ah it's just really hard to sit down
and be disciplined about it so I would
say I what I'm hearing is more and more
VCS that are increasingly skeptical of
this that are feeling you know we've got
we kind of did our quota of eyeball and
advertising deals for this fund and so
if on if you have a business model that
sort of is in that line I would strongly
strongly encourage you to figure out
another source of business economics
another business model something that
that people will pay for that is you
know there's got to be some licensing
model in there somewhere or some service
model in there somewhere other than just
eyeballs and advertising is what I would
encourage you now you know for all I
know you're the next Skype I don't know
and I'm in up then I'm giving you really
bad advice here but I would say on
average the likely odds are that you
know for for these kinds of traffic and
advertising driven deals there are 32
other companies doing pretty much the
same thing and that's going to be a real
problem when it comes not only to you
know going out there and competing in
the marketplace but convincing investors
that that this is a unique value
proposition with a sustainable
competitive advantage so the flip side
of that is you know every investor when
they look at a deal you got to spend
time thinking about how is this company
going to exit you know what's what's the
way in which we are going to get our
money back as investors you know
increasingly you can't say IPO it's
really hard
for an early stage investor to imagine
that any company that's two guys in a
garage is going to get to an IPO within
a reasonable lifetime so you know maybe
eight nine ten years from now
I mean God bless that's what it took
Cisco that's what it took Microsoft
that's what it took you know they took
nine ten years to go public right so we
can't expect an IPO that leaves you know
an M&A transaction or possibly a private
equity transaction you know another sort
of emerging model for exits but to the
extent that it's you know advertising
and eyeballs there are pretty limited
number of entities that are going to
give you a good price for that and
basically you got to be the winner to
get a good price for that kind of
business model so yes how many times
have I been involved with well I did buy
a compact computer so back in the day so
yeah let's see um where else do we go
but right the reality is that there are
probably less than 20 venture backed
companies in the history of enter
capital that have gone from 0 to 100
million in in five years so we all know
that that's the rarity so if you I mean
I'm sort of leading the questioner here
you're presenting your comment is
probably why in the world would you
expect 100 million in a business in a
financial forecast if you know they're
not going to hit it is that your
question right because the theory of the
financial forecast the theory of the
financial forecast is that we address
known challenges but we can't address
unknown challenges so so as an investor
and as an entrepreneur you know there
are going to be unknown challenges but
you can't cook them into your financials
because the question then says well why
does revenue and from year to to year 3
only go up by 5% and then it doubles the
subsequent year right which is more
likely to be the way the real
world works you know because we had a
recession because the CEO got hit by a
bus you know I mean these are all sorts
of things that happen in the real world
but you're not going to cook that into a
financial projection you're not going to
say well we're expecting the CEO to be
hit by a bus in June of 2010 and so you
know well I would you know if somebody
if so every plan that we see that comes
in that has you know your five revenues
one zero zero Millions
and the metric behind it is 7.5 percent
you know market penetration
you know we dismiss but but if you can
but there are lots of businesses that
you can design from the bottom up that
you could get to a hundred million and I
agree I agree it's more realistic that
it's going to be 40 50 60 million and I
think as I said before if you've got a
nice business model that's a perfectly
fundable deal that is a perfect do not
let me suggest to you that you shouldn't
put out a financial projection unless it
has 100 million in the fifth year but
but if you're going after something
that's interesting there should be a way
there should be a way to see how if
everything goes right you could get to
100 million because there are again 20
companies in the history of the world
that managed businesses to 100 million
within five years so we want you to
model yourself after the most successful
companies in the world within the bounds
of realism may sound unfair but that's I
mean that's the that's the psychology of
it okay all right so who are you with
I'm sorry
ah okay so you're telling me that if a
team came in with a really interesting
idea just because it said 100 million in
the fifth year you'd say forget it don't
don't waste my time
okay I mean so well there's an you know
to this point and it's a reason this is
somewhat controversial is that in my
experience there are some VCS
that are a little bit on the obsessive
compulsive side in terms of numbers and
there are some VCS who are like another
line anyway I'm not going to waste my
time and so you may in any given firm
much less between firms come across very
different VCS so you'll get one VC who
says to you you know you asked them a
question about their financial
projections and the VC will say to you
well I don't believe them anyway so I'm
not paying attention to them and you'll
get another firm another VC you ask them
a question about their financial
projections and they'll look at your
gross margin in year four and they'll
compare it to year three and year five
and they'll say I don't understand
exactly why the gross margin goes from
here to here in year four and you go oh
my god this guy's insane right but the
purpose of that question is do you
understand the underlying economics of
your business do you have a business
understanding and a financial
understanding of your business or are
you just a technologist or just a sales
guy who knows how to make Excel show 100
million dollars so I will tell you I'll
you know review I'm I'm a little on the
obsessive-compulsive side my partner's
are a little on the what the hell side
so we have that dynamic within our own
firm I don't know do you have do you
guys very are you all personally
I kind of look at the first two maybe
three years but I like also to be able
to squint my eyes and say this is going
to be a big business and I guess my
number would be over fifty but again the
as we're talking about before the bigger
the funds the more money they have to
put in the bigger multiple to pay back
the fund they're going to want the
bigger opportunities you know do get to
100 million so that you get a billion
dollar business right right so I'm sorry
we're way past time here so thank you
all very much I appreciate it